die servicewüste auf dem amt soll ein
ende haben
daher verspricht die politik den bürgern
die digitale verwaltung
wir wollen den digitalen bürgerservice
testen
dafür treffen wir vivien leigh beruflich
hilft sie internationalen fachkräften
durch den deutschen behördendschungel
mehrmals die woche muss sie dafür aufs
amt sie selbst zog 2013 mit mann und
vier kindern nach berlin
die eine erfahrung die wir natürlich
gemacht haben war terminierung das war
2013 gar nicht mal so schwer einen
termin zu bekommen aber das wurde mit
den jahren immer immer schwerer weil ich
dann auch in dem bereich gearbeitet hab
ja ich mache relocation management das
heißt wenn menschen nach berlin ziehen
dann ist einer meiner ersten gänge mit
meinen kunden bürokratischer natur und
wir gehen also zum bürgeramt und melden
diese leute an und es wurde also
wirklich immer immer schwieriger diese
termine zu bekommen und dann war eben
stand eben nicht nur das bürgeramt an
sondern auch alle möglichen anderen
sachen also auto ummelden zum beispiel
dann den kita gutschein besorgen
grundschule anmelden und so weiter
zeitmäßig ist man schon gut 15 bis 20
stunden beschäftigt pauli wo wir mal
gucken was zurzeit wir in berlin online
erledigen könnten als am zugang also
komplett online jetzt ich gehe hier rein
ich mache alles rein und dann heißt es
wirklich fertig wir können sie einmal
gucken also ich bin jetzt auf dem
serviceportal berlin ja wie man dann
gehe ich runter runter ok
online-verfahren hier so bot er alle
online-verfahren guck mal sieht aus wie
eine relativ große liste aus finden sie
denn alles was kurz urkunde ausstellung
das finde ich ganz interessant weil das
ist schwierig auch na also geburtstagen
wir da trotz der probleme mal aber hier
steht schon wieder termin suchen also in
lichtenberg urkunden stelle steht termin
buchen über termin buchen bedeutet ja
dass ich wieder hin muss ich guck mal
also es ist dort richtig oder wollen es
ist nicht wirklich online gibt es dann
einen termin
moment gucke ich mal es ist nicht einmal
aus also das gar nichts das komplett
leer
das bedeutet dass da erstmal gar nichts
ist in die probleme noch mal was haben
das andere ist okay wir wollen eine
wohnung anmelden aber und anmelden kann
man sich nicht was ich ja abstrus finde
ist dass man wenn man jetzt von der
straße in schöneberg zur straße b nach
mitte zieht dass man sich anmelden muss
und wieder zum bürgeramt gehen muss und
wieder seine sachen vorlegen muss also
das sollte man wirklich mittlerweilen
online machen können ja weil man ist ja
schon erfasst im system diese idee dass
dass man an einer zentralen stelle alles
erledigen könnte mit einer nummer wäre
natürlich eine ganz tolle geschichte
all dies ist schon heute möglich
allerdings in dänemark das kleine land
ist bei der digitalisierung ganz groß
möglich macht dies ein zentrales
personenregister darin hat jeder
einwohner eine nummer in verbindung mit
passwort und pin können die dänen damit
rund um die uhr aufs virtuelle amt
army und henrik nilsson haben in greven
gerade ein haus gekauft bauen es um und
sind mit ihren beiden kindern auch schon
eingezogen
frisch getestet besuchen wir sie das
paar ist full time berufstätig ihre
kinder gehen noch zur schule
arbeit gibt es mehr als genug also das
ist unser großes projekt kommen wir die
fliesen das macht ein fliesenleger
zum glück sind die behördengänge für die
familie kein problem
grund dafür die gesundheitskarte mit der
einheitlichen personen nummer also ich
logge mich jetzt hier ein geber an dass
ich umziehe
dann bekomme ich einen code der nicht
verifizieren muss ich bin wirklich die
die sich einloggen will das mache ich
mit meinem smartphone dann ist die
berufstätige mutter schon fast fertig
sie gibt ihr umzug staaten ein und die
sache ist erledigt steuer
krankenversicherung auto und rente alles
wird damit automatisch aktualisiert wenn
man sich in deutschland um melden will
muss man oft stundenlang warten und
nummern ziehen
was würden sie zu so einen service sagen
ich denke das ist ein wenig altmodisch
so ganz ohne die vorteile der digitalen
welt warum macht man das nicht so
einfach wie möglich für die menschen die
diese dienste nutzen
mit einer nummer kann man alle
behördengänge virtuell erledigen
auch in deutschland sollen bald dänische
verhältnisse herrschen
das wurde so im online zugangs gesetz
festgelegt der sollen ein einheitliches
bürger konto bekommen
papier akten werden abgeschafft die
verwaltung city komplett erneuert bis
ende 2022 muss das fertig sein dann
sollen bürger und unternehmen
behördengänge etwa für den antrag auf
kindergeld oder eine geburtsurkunde
online machen können
[Musik]
575 behördendienste sollen uns bis ende
2022 komplett online zur verfügung stehe
doch so komplex ist die modernisierung
strukturieren
bund länder gemeinden gremien
organisationen und sich andere mischen
mit die programme sollen dabei von einem
etwa einer kommune für alle anderen mit
entwickelt werden
und die sollen die neue software in ihre
vorhandenen systeme integrieren
doch die software landschaft ist in
einem wildwuchs entstanden jede
verwaltung nutzt andere systeme
überall ist jemand anderes zuständig
niemand kann zentral anordnen dass nun
jede stadt eine bestimmte neue software
übernehmen muss und auch technisch ist
das nicht so einfach
beim deutschen beamtenbund ist vize chef
friedhelm schäfer der it fachmann
er diskutiert seit jahren über die
modernisierungspläne mit der
bundesregierung ein riesenproblem ist
das system chaos sie haben geräte die
aus dem letzten jahrhundert kommen die
im einsatz sind sie haben wir top modern
ausgestattete verwaltung sie haben
software
na ja die würde heute keiner mehr
anfassen nach dem motto das ist wirklich
digitale steinzeit wasser da neue
software in eine bestehende
it-landschaft integrieren bei zigtausend
verschiedenen alt programmen computer
systemen und netzwerken kann das klappen
da habe ich meine zweifel
ich bringe mal ein beispiel der bundes
entwickelt eine software die genutzt
werden soll im kommunalen bereich
dann haben sie in deutschland 11.000
bürgermeister die dastehen und sagen oh
schön und wie kriege ich das jetzt in
meine rechner welt implementiert wie
funktioniert das
es ist fraglich ob die modernisierung so
überhaupt in diesem jahr zehn zu
schaffen ist
dabei ist deutschland digitale
verwaltung im internationalen vergleich
ohnehin abgeschlagen platz 22 von 27 in
der eu bei den online behörden diensten
rang 61 im un index zur digitalen
teilhabe der bürger hinter armenien und
oman das chaos in deutschland erwies
sich bei der korona pandemie sogar als
gefährlich
informationen zu infizierten konnten
nicht digital ausgetauscht werden
fallzahlen waren nicht aktuell
auch in bad belzig gab es probleme wie
in fast allen gesundheitsämtern
amtsärzte den karren brinkmann und
pressesprecherin andrea metzler sind im
corona krisenstab zu beginn der pandemie
kämpfen sie mit veralteter technik und
personalmangel herausforderung war
natürlich im bereich der minderen
ausstattung technischen ausstattung dass
wir alle meldungen per fax bekommen
haben die ganzen befunde die reihen kam
mussten ja auch händisch eingegeben
werden sie sind in der flut von papier
regelrecht getrunken
die papierflut stammt aus den laboren
das ergebnis der korona tests wurde
lange zeit per fax an das gesundheitsamt
gesandt und dort händisch in die
computer eingetippt erst seit anfang
dieses jahres ist die digitale
übertragung mit dem programm dem es die
regel
das zeitaufwendige eintippen beim
gesundheitsamt entfällt damit dass im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst noch
gefaxt wird statt digitaler vernetzung
war bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
jahrelang bekannt
es ist vernetzen der gesundheitsämter
ist mindestens zehn jahre alte debatte
auch dem ist das digital das
elektronische meldesystem schiff glaube
ich zehn jahren im gesetz seit dem 11
ist es endlich auch bei 100 prozent das
zum beispiel bei saas q2 die labore die
elektronisch melden und lange jahre
wurde das digitale meldesystem
verschlafen verantwortung für die
verzögerung übernimmt niemand vom robert
koch institut heißt es dazu lapidar man
sei von einem it projekt des bundes
abhängig gewesen und es habe personal
gefehlt
die leidtragenden dieses bundes
versagens waren örtliche
gesundheitsämter ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wir sollten wir tun es blieb
einfach nur die möglichkeit mit den
mitteln die wir hatten zu arbeiten auch
wenn es anstrengend und belastend war
die mitarbeiter ja auch extra schichten
an den wochenenden geschoben haben
wir sitzen im stab und fragen uns schon
immer wasser was denkt man sich
eigentlich darum man fühlt sich hier
einfach auch manchmal ja allein gelassen
und auch ich sag es mal drastisch frau
scheiterte auch weil es die gitarre
nicht funktionierte gab es überlastungen
chaos und fehler
so verschickte das gesundheitsamt im
januar eine quarantäne anordnung ganze
zweieinhalb monate zu spät
[Musik]
der mathematiker jobst heitzig hatte
mitte oktober 2020 kontakt zu einer
infizierten person corona er begab sich
selbst in quarantäne und informierte
telefonisch sein gesundheitsamt knapp
drei monate später kommt ein brief der
behörde
bei ihnen besteht der verdacht dass sie
sich mit diesem virus angesteckt haben
könnten
also hab ich natürlich erst mal gedacht
wo kann ich mich denn jetzt hier
angesteckt haben tödliche krankheit ist
ja nicht so witzig wenn man so was
gesagt kriegt und aufgrund dessen müssen
sie für 14 tage in eine häusliche
quarantäne bis einschließlich 6 11 2020
nun habe ich also gelesen 611 moment das
ist ja noch zehn monate hin
das kann doch nicht sein und habe ich
noch mal gelesen dass wir 2020 das ist
ja in der vergangenheit so und dann war
mir dann fiel der groschen an war mir
klar das bezieht sich auf diesen fall
von vor zweieinhalb monaten
man fasst sich an kaufen und denkt wie
kann das sein er hat sich war im
landkreis potsdam mittelmark kein
einzelfall
seit januar 2021 haben sie hier mit
erheblich mehr personal und der
weitgehenden abschaffung der faxe nun
die situation im griff
doch mitten in der hochphase der
pandemie versucht der bund eine neue
software zentral durchzusetzen
und zwar zur kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung denn alle die kontakt mit
einem infizierten hatten sind ja zu
erfassen zu informieren und zu isolieren
bund und länder wollen dass dafür
deutschlandweit das programm besonders
verwendet wird 90% nutzer rate streben
sie an innerhalb kürzester zeit aber es
gibt probleme
wir wenden uns an data bund einen
verband von it unternehmen die stellen
software auch für gesundheitsämter her
hier hat man wenig verständnis für die
einführung von sommers mit dem programm
wurde nun sogar gut laufende staatliche
software ersetzt etwa in bayern das für
afrika entwickelte sommers passen nur
schwer in die komplexe it struktur
deutscher gesundheitsämter es gab dort
hoch entwickelte lösungen die man aber
nicht kannte in der politik wenn man
sich halt nicht intensiv mit den dingen
auseinander gesetzt hat man hat nicht
mit den gesundheitsämtern geredet man
hat nicht mit der software herstellern
geredet und da kommt es natürlich zu
solchen fehlleistungen sage ich jetzt
mal und viel beurteilung vor allen
dingen also wichtig ist eigentlich dass
bei solchen entscheidung die fachleute
vorher mit einbezogen werden und nicht
am runden tisch einfach irgendwelche
dinge entschieden werden der aktenlage
vom bundesgesundheitsminister heißt es
dazu lediglich schriftlich das von
sommers ein wichtiger beitrag zur
pandemie bewältigung geleistet wird und
man tauschte sich mit den
gesundheitsämtern aus
gegen die eiligen software vorgaben vom
bund sträuben sich viele
gesundheitsämter in hannover ist eines
der grössten verantwortlich für den
schutz von 1,2 millionen menschen mehr
als 750 mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
managen die krise mit einer software
namens aesculap ein umstieg auf das vom
bund empfohlene programm sommers mitten
in der pandemie kommt für den
regierungspräsidenten hauke jagau nicht
in frage warum tun sie das nicht weil
wir zusammen gebrochen werden wir haben
ich hab das ja gesagt werden zum teil
jetzt 750 menschen die alle auf dieses
system geschult sind und wir hatten in
den in der jetzt kasse hinter uns
liegenden phase wo wir manchmal 300 neue
infektionen an einem tag hatten plus den
kontaktpersonen mussten wir ganz schnell
arbeiten können und da müssen sie mit
dem arbeiten was eingespielt ist und da
kann ich doch nicht sagen du musst mal
umstellen das wäre so als wenn sie
irgendein piloten der in der luft ist
sagte dass auch wir bauen wir mal
schnell die computer aus mit denen dein
ding fliegt und und das geht alles
anders das geht einfach nicht
der bund macht mittlerweile druck bei
der durchsetzung seiner softwarelösung
es wird versucht fehler beim
krisenmanagement den gesundheitsämtern
zuzuschieben
und das hat mich auch geärgert dass man
dann so tut als ob es daran liegt dass
was nicht funktioniert weil nicht alle
sommers anwenden das zeigt wie so häufig
dass man auf der bundesebene
glaubt man macht ein gesetz und dann
ändert sich die welt
kein wunder dass bürgerinnen und bürger
langsam an ihrer verwaltung verzweifeln
werden in berlin weiß die politik seit
jahren wo es bei der verwaltungssoftware
hakt um die dauerbaustelle besser in den
griff zu bekommen wird ein it
dienstleistungszentrum aufgebaut
das soll eigentlich die gesamte berliner
behörden dezentral betreuen und es wurde
eine eigene it staatssekretärin ernannt
für die gleiche aufgabe werden sich
verschiedene programme genutzt
die heißen im amtsdeutsch fachverfahren
können sie diese kritik an diesem
handwerkszeug mit dem man jeden tag
umgehen muss nachvollziehen
da kommt also ich will ihnen nur eine
zahl sagen wir haben über 500
fachverfahren in der berliner verwaltung
sind einige dabei
das sind noch selbst gestrickte aus dem
letzten jahrtausend
aber es gibt auch einige fachverfahren
wo in den letzten jahren sehr viel
passiert ist und wenn man dann das pech
hat an einem alten fachverfahren
arbeiten zu müssen dann verstehe ich das
aber auch hier hat sich die welt weiter
gedreht
warum kann man die dinger nicht einfach
austauschen einfach austauschen
in berlin geht das nicht ganz so einfach
weil wir wenn wir über die erneuerung
eines fach verfahrens reden über mehrere
hundert manchmal mehrere tausend
nutzerinnen und nutzer mit
unterschiedlichen anforderungen sprechen
die in unterschiedlichsten
verwaltungseinheiten und gebäuden sitzen
und insofern ist jedes fach verfahrens
projekt ein großprojekt
selbst bei der strafverfolgung ist
vielerorts die lage eine katastrophe
das sagt uns der bund deutscher
kriminalbeamter es beginne schon bei der
erfassung von beweismitteln ein beispiel
am tatort wird ein stift sichergestellt
was passiert da natürlich dieser stift
würde beispielsweise jetzt in so eine
art erwarten tüte wandern und dann würde
man halt diesen barcode darauf kleben
dann würde man in das
vorgangsbearbeitung system händisch
diesen barcode abtippen müssen weil man
eben händisch vermögen nicht eins gehen
kann aber dafür ist ja da das ist
richtig wir verlangen auch nach dieser
schnittstelle seit vielen vielen jahren
aber das ist ein programmierung aufwand
der nicht geleistet wird der kostet geld
das kostet wahnsinnig ressource weil pro
tatort wo teilweise hunderte
beweismittel sichergestellt werden
ja mehrere tage damit zugebracht werden
müssen
diese barcodes händisch einzutippen da
kommen im jahr zehntausende
arbeitsstunden nur für das ziffern
tippen zusammen
wir wenden uns an die polizei hamburg
hier arbeiten sie inzwischen unter
hochdruck an der modernisierung von
software und hardware martin voll bricht
ist seit kurzem für einen teil davon
verantwortlich das programm zur
vorgangsbearbeitung ist eine altlast so
und an der stelle vorgangsbearbeitung
system ist die not aus meiner sicht
jetzt nicht so groß dass wir zwingend um
eine ein lese möglichkeit zu schaffen
dort erhebliche gelder in die hand
nehmen müssen um diese zu investieren
insbesondere weil das programm schon
auch entsprechend betagt ist das
verstehe ich so also es hat für sich
jetzt nicht mehr die priorität
ja die prioritäten müssen natürlich
immer wieder gewichtet werden also die
die kritik ist ja berechtigt die dort
geäußert würden so die polizeiführung
und die it leitung ist aber natürlich in
der verpflichtung zu gucken so welche
dieser ganzen kritikpunkte die an uns
herangetragen werden müssen wir
eigentlich wie priorisieren
es werde nun darüber verhandelt die
vorgangsbearbeitung software zu ersetzen
wann ist noch nicht klar doch es gibt
noch viel mehr kritik
denn bei der verbrechensbekämpfung
stehen heute oft daten im zentrum der
ermittlungen
die datenauswertung wird immer wichtiger
und hat mittlerweile schon eine
wahnsinnig große bedeutung
das liegt daran dass immer mehr delikte
auch online geschehen und
kommunikationsdaten im wesentlichen
nahezu aller delikts felder eine große
rolle spielen
doch auf die daten etwa aus handys
werden ermittler bis zu 15 monate
das hat viele folgen verschiedenste
folgen wenn ich diese handydaten brauche
als beweismittel beispielsweise um einen
durchsuchungsbeschluss oder vielleicht
eine haft entscheidung eines richters
herbeizuführen
dann kann mich nicht 15 monate darauf
waren die auswirkungen der langsamen
datensicherung bei der verfolgung von
straftätern sind gravierend ja das
verfahren verzögert sich natürlich
immens das ist gar keine frage
wir haben natürlich auch schon immer
wieder nachfragen von der
staatsanwaltschaft von den gerichten
wann wird denn dieses handy ausgewertet
oder aus oder oder gesichert bis hin zu
wenn das sage ich mal zu lange dauert
das dann teilweise auch beweismittel
wieder ausgehändigt werden müssen weil
die verhältnismäßigkeit nicht mehr da
ist
im klartext straftäter können davon
kommen weil die polizeidaten nicht
schnell genug sichern kann
mit problemen wie in hamburg kämpfen
sicherheitsbehörden in der ganzen
republik
digitales karos finden wir auf allen
ebenen bei bund ländern und gemeinden
für uns bürger gibt es kaum
online-services es fehlen klare
strukturen realistische strategien und
eindeutige verantwortlichkeiten für ganz
deutschland
[Musik]